merci jean baptiste avec charles pasqua
s'est donc simone nouvelles le ministre
des affaires sociales qui sera chargé de
mettre en oeuvre la politique des
banlieues et la politique de la ville
simone veil l'a répété à la sortie du
conseil qui n'était pas question de
revenir sur les allocations familiales
allouées aux familles d'enfants
délinquants
une mise au point qui fait suite aux
dernières déclarations de pascal clément
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
simone veil -le au micro de nathalie
saint cricq soit je crois qu'il ya une
confusion dans les propositions qui ont
pu être faites au des décisions il ya un
maire communiste kke a décidé d'en
supprimer les aides qui était donné par
sa commune aux familles on peut s'en
étonner sur le fond parce que de priver
de soutien pour les cantines scolaires
cela fait un an qu'on nous mêmes des
frères dont prôné dans la douceur
rencontre délinquante cette même mesure
tout à fait tout à fait inhumaines et
injuste parce que c'est une décision
concernant des crédits il au commerce
concerne les allocations familiales
il n'en est pas question
c'est clair et on ne peut pas du tout
envisagé par des mesures qui seraient
plus ou moins arbitraires de supprimer
dans l'allocation familiale et de
pénaliser l'ensemble de l'humanité s'il
ya un lien tout était faux sang ne
pourra jamais être la philosophie
gouvernementale ça n'est pas la
philosophie gouvernementales et on doit
prendre le nouveau texte en matière de
protection de l'enfance c'est exception
pays parlent parfois laisserait qu'il
est par le bas rhin dormir en détail
mais cette question ne sera pas si on va
essayer de contenir des procédures
existent et vous permet d'intervenir
dans ce cas précis on peut à certaines
conditions qui sont des conditions
il ya toutes les garanties de l'habitude